hello everyone and welcome to the only
thing that interests you today it is of
course the semi-final match between uh
Fabiano caruana and Pregnant and this is
the first game that we are going to
cover so uh to sum it up a little bit uh
the first two classical games they
played ended in a draw then they played
two rapid games uh the 25 minute ones
and both of those games ended in a draw
as well but what happened in the first
game of that 25 minute rapid uh is uh
very very interesting this is the
position from uh one of the games uh
where Fabi had the white pieces uh so
let me just switch that up a little bit
sorry Fabi had the white pieces here and
he had a winning position against Prague
he could have played Ponte A6 which
would start advancing his past Pawn but
he didn't just to give you an idea of
how if you want to soak up the position
a little bit before I just showing the
move so this is the position uh Prague
gave up the exchange sorry if I would
give up the exchange he has a bishop
versus Rook but he already has a fast
Pawn on A5 and he really needs to start
pushing it uh and this is the idea of
Pawn to A6 now if you start checking a
little bit Ruby to check King to C7 and
now Rook A2 going after the pawn then
King to B6 comes and now Rook to B2
check isn't all that impressive because
you can just block with the bishop and
then the pawn just wins so what you will
do here is just go after the pawn Rook
captures an F2 but now look at this A7
and after Rook day two of course going
after the pawn bishop to D5 now you you
will try to put the bishop on A6 and
promote the pawn black of course will
not allow this uh Fabi will uh or rather
Prague will try to sacrifice The Rook
for the pawn and then try and get a draw
here but it will not work Rook day for
for example Bishop to B3 will attack The
Rook let's say Rook day one and now
you're gonna play Bishop to C4 if you
can play Bishop to A6 and close off the
Rook then you're uh gonna win by pushing
the pawn all the way uh so here you will
have to play Rook captures on A7 King
captures and now uh even though it seems
like the white king is so far away uh it
actually takes much much less for the
the white king to go over to the king
side for example King E7 you can go
forward because the F1 the F7 Pawn will
be hanging King to B6 F5 and now after
King to C6 and King to F6 the bishop
covers D6 Square already you are on D5
uh shouldering of the the black king
king G5 you're gonna play King to E5 and
that's pretty much it yeah you're up a
piece your opponent is up a pawn but not
really uh something uh that you can push
for uh for a draw here so this would
have been completely winning for Fabi
the problem is Fabi did not start with
Ponte a65 he played Pawn to F4 uh and
this allowed frog to draw the game
because now he just gave um uh Prague an
extra Tempo he played King to F5 now the
pawn is hanging and also uh his F7 Pawn
is not hanging like in the line that
we've shown and now A6 uh Rook to B2
with check King to C7 Rook to A2 and now
King to B6 with King captures on F4 and
now Bishop the D5 of course uh Fabi will
try to keep the Rook off of the pawn but
just Rook captures and 6 King captures
and now King to G3 and now you can see
that the black king is already all the
way here the white thing is only
starting his journey from the a file
King to B5 Pawn to F5 King to C5 now we
have G5 King to D4 and now Pawn to G4
and this is how uh Prague exchanges
everything captures captures King to E5
we have Pawn to H5 and now King to F5
with Advantage for King G5 Pawn to H3
and here captures captures and Bishop to
C6 we have uh H2 Bishop D5 and H1 Queen
Bishop captures an H1 and here we have a
draw by insufficient material so Bobby
definitely had a chance here he didn't
take it and the next game of the 25
minute rapid section also ended in a
draw which means we are now going into
the 10 minute Rapids and this is the
first game of the time in the Rapids
we're now uh pragnananda has the white
pieces and this is the game that we will
truly focus on so let's see what
happened in this one uh uh pregnant
opens with Ponte E4
now we have found the E5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to C4 in case
anyone is joining us and was not
following what's been happening in the
video World Cup so far this is the
semi-finals and Pregnant and Fabiano
caruana are fighting at uh uh well for
the for the honor and privilege of
facing Magnus Carlsen in the finals of
defeated World Cup so a lot is it let's
take care we have Knight to F6 D3 Bishop
to E7 and both players Castle so this is
also a very standard theory of the
Italian game of the two knights opening
uh with Knight the C3 D6 and now Pawn to
A4 and here we have Bishop to G4 H3 and
now Bishop to H5 and now Bishop to E3
and now Knight to D4 putting pressure on
the uh the Knight here so of course you
do not want to see something like Knight
captures on F3 where you're gonna have
to mess up your Pawn structure so here
Bishop captures on D4 was played uh of
course G4 is is possible but uh Prague
doesn't want to allow Fabi to go for
some Knight captures and G4 action
captures cash actress in the year it's
just gonna I mean this is just gonna be
very annoying you're gonna have to take
the the bishop the Knight here as well
and after Knight D5 You're Gonna Play
Bill something like Bishop to G5 and you
know once F5 comes in the queen finds
her way all the way to the king side uh
it's not white who's playing for the win
here it's definitely black so of course
uh just Bishop captures on D4 uh we have
uh captures on D4 and now Knight to D5
offering a trade here Knight captures
Bishop captures and just kicking the
bishop back with Pawn to C6 with Bishop
back to B3 and the bishop captures on F3
Queen characters and uh up until this
point is move 14 it's all been uh Theory
uh there are games where A5 and queen to
A5 were played but here we have won the
G6 by Fabi and it is now as of move 14
that we have a completely new game so
okay we have Queen to G4 uh Prague has
an excellent Bishop here he wants to
play F4 F5 and start opening up the
black king so of course uh King to G7
Bobby uh gets off of this diagonal as
soon as possible possible and pawn to F4
now you can do some Rook to Rook at the
E1 maybe Rook F3 to G3 maybe just push
F5 maybe many ideas here all depends on
how far we plays this uh Queen to C7
developing the queen connecting Rooks
and Rook 8 to E1 we have Rook 88 and now
Queen back to F3 uh Queen to D7 uh if
you're wondering uh why not just Advance
the pawn here it doesn't really do all
that much once the king move from this
diagonal F5 is just not as potent you
can just play Bishop to F6 and the end
ignore the pawn I think nothing is
really happening here so instead we have
Queen to F3 preparing it and now Queen
to D7 we have Rook D2 preparing to
double up on the E file or on the file
depending on what Fabi plays and the
bishop to d8 Now The Rook now nicely
controls the file King to H1 and now uh
we have Pawn to D5 and this is a very
tricky move by Fabi which if not handled
properly like let's say you play Pawn to
E5 then Pawn to F6 and Fabi solves all
of his problems for example captures
captures and okay you can double up on
the on the E file it's a root capture 72
Queen capture so now Queen to F5 and not
a worry in the world a perfectly fine
position for for uh Fabi and this bishop
on B3 is of a questionable uh quality so
after D5 proxies all right show me what
you had in mind E Capture Sun D5 Rook
character Sun E2 and now Queen captures
on E2 and now just Rook to E8 the
problem is if you play C captures on D5
kind of recapturing the pond and queen
E5 check and you're just gonna uh pick
it up again so that's why Fabi first
play Rook d8 attacking the queen but now
Prague throws a nice situation suit here
uh B captures on C6 and he attacks
fabi's queen as well it's okay B
captures and now Queen to F2 and now uh
what five you should have played is Rook
to E3 uh as it's just a very very uh
strong move he did play it eventually
but maybe right away would have been the
way to go for example Queen to E8 and
now after a trade here you do get the
passport on E3 I thought we got a in a
similar fashion he played Queen to D6
first uh the idea being that now if uh
Prague tries Rook to E1 you can just
trade for example captures captures and
then pick up the F4 Pawn as well but of
course Prague doesn't do that he just
defends the pawn pawn to G3 and now Fabi
goes for Rook to E3 now
um this is just you know a huge bone in
in your throat uh Rook to E1 and now uh
Bishop to B6 nicely defending everything
here we have King to G2 and now Queen to
F6 uh we have Bishop to C4 uh hoping to
get B4 in but of course uh Fabi stops
that with Pawn to A5 Queen to F1 and now
Bishop to C5 we have Rook captures on E3
the captures okay the pass Pawn is
created and now Pawn to C3 and now the
problem for Fab is uh Prague is already
up a pawn and if he can get something
like Queen Queen to F3 to get the king
over to E2 and play D4 a cut out to the
at the dark Square Bishop from defending
the 3 Pawn then he will be able to just
pick up that pawn there's no way to
defend it and then he's gonna be up to
pawns which is a lot but okay if Queens
get traded off Bishops are of opposite
color of course you know what that means
uh so Bishop back to B6 Fabi finds a way
to complicate things with Queen to F3
now comes Queen to E7 preparing to push
the pass Pawn so King to F1 of course
now king and queen are guarding the E2
Square Bishop to A7 we have King to E2
and now Queen to B7 putting pressure on
the B2 Pawn B3 and queen to E7 now and
finally of course Prague plays onto D4
and what is Fabi to do about the E3 Pawn
well he finds the very nice C5 move now
what is the idea here the idea is that
if you trade now then of course uh he
can just trade captures captures
captures on d4c captures and uh Prague
would be up to pawns but uh Bishops are
of opposite color and uh okay the the
engine says the position is completely
winning for white but when you're
playing this and this is a 10 minute
rapid game of course you cannot know
these things even if you are at the
level of Prague and Fabi so he doesn't
over push it he plays Spawn to D5 this
locks out the bishop and he's gonna
capture the pawn next so here we have
Bishop to B8 and now Queen captures an
E3 uh Queen to f8 of course now Fabi
will avoid the queen trade and Bishop to
B5 we have Queen back to D6 going after
the pawn and Bishop to C6 now we have
Bishop to C7 now Fabi needs to keep an
eye on the other pawns here because if
if B4 at any point becomes as possible
or if you capture one of the pawns then
of course the game is just over King to
D3 now a Prague finds an ingenious idea
of hiding the the king over at uh favi's
Queen side we have Queen to F6 and now
uh well you could capture on C5 and
allow some Queen to F5 action going
after the H3 Pawn uh Prague just goes up
the board King to C4 with Bishop to D6
defending the pawn now Queen to E4 uh we
have Pawn to G5 and just F captures and
G5 Fabi accepts the challenge uh rather
uh probably except the challenge and
Fabi will now have to try something
Queen to F1 check Queen to D3 now all
the queen trades are of course winning
for uh pregnant Queen captures on H3 now
King to B5 and here we have Queen to G4
uh if you go Bishop to C7 or something
to the guard upon then even D6 is is
perfectly fine and completely winning so
Queen to G4 was played and now King
captures an A5 we have Queen captures
and G5 King to B5 and Bishop capture
person G3 so now Prague is only up by
one Pawn but it's the past a pawn and of
course he does not want to make the same
mistake Fabi made in the previous game
that we've just seen where Fabi did not
Advance the past Pawn here Prague
advances it onto A5 we have Bishop to D6
Now Pawn to A6 we have Queen to E7 and
of course Queen to F3 uh Bishop to B8
now guarding that A7 square and just
Queen to G4 with check we have King to
H6 now comes Queen to C8 forcing the
bishop to move back uh Bishop to F4 and
now Queen to D7 this is Abu gain control
of the seventh Rank and now A7 is coming
we have Queen to E2 with check King all
the way to B6 we have Pawn to C4 and now
Pawn to B4 we have Queen to E3 with
check King to B5 and queen captures and
C3 but now of course you gain a Tempo uh
so Pawn to A7 uh we have Queen to D3 now
trying to get C3 in which Tempo but uh
course prognos it doesn't matter A8
Queen we have C3 opening up a discovery
here King to B6 and queen to E3 with
check King to B7 and down five is out of
options he has to go for it pawn to C2
and now if he can get his Queen into the
game okay then he will definitely have a
fighting chance but the problem is it's
actually a force mate in nine and uh
proc finds it uh Queen to f8 with Chuck
King the G5 and queen to G7 check and he
was in this position on move 63 that uh
that Fabiano Corona resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
at once uh King H5 or King cage 4 is
played then either Queen from G7
delivers Checkmate on G4 or queen from
D7 delivers Checkmate and G4 uh you can
have your picks so there you have it uh
uh pregnant that takes the first win in
the 10 minute rapid section which means
that now Fabi has to equalize in the
second game of the 10 minute rapid
section and that game I will now tell
you what happened in that game uh that
game ended in a draw which means that
fragdananda wins and the Prague will
meet Magnus Carlsen in the finals or
defeated World Cup so absolutely
incredible Prague was even better he was
even winning for the better part of the
game but he just wasn't trying to win he
was just trying not to lose and
sometimes that can very well go against
you but he played it uh so calmly so I
mean he he played it perfectly if you if
you don't want to lose that's the way to
do it and that's definitely the way he
did it so yeah he eliminated everyone
for those of you who are just tuning in
I would just tell you who are the who
who is everyone that he eliminated he
defeated a grand master Maxim Lagarde he
defeated the Grand Master David Nevada
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura Grand Master
ference berkish Grandmaster Arjun
erikaisy and now he eliminated Fabiano
caruana of course Grandmaster Fabiana
corvana he limited world number three he
eliminated world number two now the only
question remains is can he eliminate
world number one Magnus Carlsen we will
find out tomorrow what do you think
everyone facing Magnus is definitely an
underdog regardless of how well they've
been playing the tournament is just how
strong Magnus is uh where are uh
pregnant's chances do you think his
chances lying the classical do you think
his chances are in the rapid section if
so which rapid section the 25 minute one
the 10 minute one the blitz section in
the five minutes I mean could be
anything could happen I mean I I I would
I would love for Prague to win uh but
you know he's gonna have to work really
hard but I will also love the viewers to
win so I would like to see classical
games drawn and I would like to for them
to go into the rapid tie breaks uh but
yeah we'll see what happens uh
beautifully done by Prague and
eliminating former World Championship
challenge or Fabiana corvana I mean
absolutely masterful uh so I mean I
could just continue praising him but I
mean he's achieved all of this it is
definitely not necessary uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh brilliantly done uh so I mean there
you have it I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Brahm and I would like
to thank Wives and Lovers Robert Bloom
uh
guernseychessfestival.org.gg and Phil
mouth this for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals of
the fide World Cup until it finishes uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day